der Tierarzt hat etwas richtig komisches
aus dem Bauch von unserem Huhn
rausgezogen der Bauch ist nicht mehr
ganz so dick wie hier das war noch
letzte Woche trotzdem haben wir den
jetzt punktiert und diese Flüssigkeit
haben wir aus dem Bauch rausgezogen die
Flüssigkeit sieht einfach haargenau aus
wie flüssiges Eigelb aber das kann doch
nicht sein wir haben das jetzt ins Labor
geschickt und hoffen dass wir ganz bald
wissen ob wir wie immer noch weiter
helfen können sie macht eigentlich einen
guten Eindruck und solange würde ich sie
auf jeden Fall noch nicht erlösen aber
wenn klar ist dass sie das nicht
überlebt dann bleibt uns wahrscheinlich
keine Wahl